han sido necesarios un mes y medio casi
400.000 contagios para que tienen forma
de los primeros muertos en el brote de
coronavirus en shanghai se trata de tres
ancianos de entre 89 y 91 años con
enfermedades previas como cáncer o
diabetes que les habían impedido
vacunarse la prensa local e
internacional y habían informado en las
últimas semanas de ancianos muertos en
asilos después de haber dado positivo
pero que no habían pasado a engrosar las
estadísticas oficiales porque china
sacaba sus muertes a enfermedades
previas esos tres fallecidos sugieren un
cambio en el criterio contable sobre el
que sólo hay especulaciones quizás china
quiera combatir la incredulidad sobre
sus cifras de fallecidos o quizá quiera
convencer a los millones de
shanghaineses encerrados en sus casas
algunos durante más de un mes de que sus
sufrimientos no son en vano esos tres
fallecidos sin embargo subrayan el gran
peligro de la pandemia en china el 90%
de la población está vacunada pero el
porcentaje baja dramáticamente en el
caso de los ancianos sólo el 38 por
ciento de los mayores 60 años tienen la
pauta completa en shanghai según las
cifras oficiales el anuncio de las
cifras de los tres primeros muertos
coincide con las del desarrollo
económico el pib creció en el primer
trimestre de este año un 4,8 por ciento
es un ritmo ligeramente superior al del
último trimestre pero ya advierten los
expertos que las consecuencias del
encierro en shanghai se empezarán a
notar a partir del siguiente